good morning welcome to sky news
breakfast
the prime minister boris johnson and
carrie simons have married in secret
the two tied the knot in a small
ceremony at westminster cathedral in
central london on saturday
downing street has declined to comment
on the reports but mps and ministers
have sent their congratulations to the
couple
our political correspondent rob powell
reports a warning his report does
contain flashing images
not tied now confirmed boris johnson and
carrie simons married yesterday in a
secret
ceremony in central london the service
took place
in front of a small group of family and
friends who were invited at the last
minute
amid strict secrecy and this is the
venue westminster cathedral
around a mile from downing street
covered rules would have permitted just
30 people to be in attendance here
at the largest catholic church in the
country last night musicians were seen
leaving number 10 with some family
members spotted earlier
but inside government officials and mps
were reluctant to comment on the news
at first all of the usual channels of
information out of here appeared to have
gone silent with no comment
or no confirmation about whether the
prime minister of the united kingdom was
a married man once again
newspapers even reported that some
senior number 10 aides were unaware
of what had gone on rumors of a
relationship between the couple first
emerged in 2018
while the then foreign secretary was
still married to his second wife by the
autumn of 2019 and with boris johnson
now prime minister
the pairing was out in the open with
carrie simons pictured celebrating the
conservatives election win
inside downing street
2020 brought the announcement of the
couple's first child
a baby boy named wilfred and the news
that they were engaged
this will be boris johnson's third
marriage and carry simon's first
and despite a colorful and much
publicized private life
the prime minister still rarely opens up
about what goes on behind closed doors
a reticence that seems to run against
the reputation
of this most public of politicians rob
powell sky news in westminster
all right well let's speak to our
reporter aisha zahud who's down at
westminster cathedral for us this
morning
aisha saw a secret ceremony but lots of
congratulations for the pm and carrie
yeah we've seen lots of congratulations
poor and yes political figures now
the ceremony was tightly guarded and
safely kept secret it took place here
at westminster cathedral yesterday
afternoon amongst close
family and friends of course with
covered guidance weddings are restricted
to 30 people
at the moment now the couple got engaged
back in december 2019 and welcomed their
first son
in april of last year and it's boris
johnson's third
marriage and it's the first time a prime
minister will be married while serving
in
office now we've seen a number of tweets
pouring from political figures so let's
take a look at some of them we had
arlene foster first minister of northern
ireland say
huge congratulations to boris johnson
and carrie simons on your wedding today
similarly conservative mp therese coffey
said congratulations boris johnson
and carrie simons on your marriage today
and then on the flip side john trickett
labor mp and former shadow minister for
the cabinet office said
boris secret wedding a good way to bury
this week's
bad news covered indian variant dominic
cummings testimony
who should we allow to die fishy goings
on in number 10 flat
the richest get even richer richer etc
etc so as you can see there
whilst we've had lots of congratulations
pouring in it has elicited a mixed
response okay aisha thank you
also and celebrations continue
throughout the night outside chelsea's
stamford bridge ground
in west london have a look at this
look at it london has just
shut down because we have won the
champions league
and i hope it does not open another week
thousands flock to the streets near the
club's home ground and celebrated
winning football's biggest club
competition
by hugging and singing songs long into
the night
for months now the government has set
its sights on a full relaxation of
restrictions in england from the 21st of
june but writing in the observer this
morning labour leader sakirshama has
said that the prime minister
and his cabinet are too busy quote
covering their own backs to properly
counter the threat
posed by the india variant and with
cases increasing across the uk
new research suggests the public may be
becoming less confident about the
roadmap relaxation date
new research from the polling company
opinion has found 43
of people now support the postponement
of the june 21st lockdown using
and that compares to 34 percent of
people who think it should go ahead as
planned
and 10 who think it should be brought
forward
meanwhile more than half of people in
their 30s in england have received a
coronavirus vaccination in a period of
just over two weeks
nhs england says since it started
opening up the rollout to those in their
30s that happened on the 13th of may
53 of the age group have been given at
least
one dose of the vaccine
i'm joined now by dr anil mehta a fellow
of the royal college of gp's doctor good
morning thanks so much for talking to us
that's quite a statistic
isn't it half of people in their 30s
have had the first jab in a little over
two weeks
good morning good morning kimberly thank
you very much for giving me the time yes
it is i mean i think
since the vaccination program started
way back in december we've been at it
uh day and night really in terms of
numbers of uh people that we're getting
through our doors we've achieved very
high numbers
in the older adults but what we're now
seeing is
is the younger adults coming up and
asking and inquiring and responding to
the invitations for their vaccinations
so yes it's been a remarkable
vaccination program uh in the entire
history of the nhs and look we don't
know what's going to happen in the
future with mutations etc etc
but at the moment we we're on a mission
in terms of
getting as many people vaccinated both
through the first and second doses so
really really pleased this morning
you've been doing vaccinations haven't
you
yes we we've run a vaccination clinic
from our
gp practice in in redbridge in northeast
london and um you know we
all our team of of gps doctors nurses
healthcare assistants
have have worked tirelessly over the
past few months in terms of
inviting people um and making sure that
we give them the confidence to say
actually
this is absolutely safe this is
essential and this is the only way that
we will unlock our
society in general so i think we've
we've only got one mission at the moment
because confidence is key isn't it um i
just
wonder when you're giving out these jabs
do you see perhaps less hesitancy
in younger people two weeks more than
half
of people who are now eligible in their
30s have had that jab
do you think there is less hesitancy in
the younger people i think kimberley is
really varied because i think
the power is in the persuasive uh
discussions that
doctors and nurses will have with their
patients to say look this is
because people do have uh genuine
concerns
and as evidence emerges of issues with
vaccines etc
we will have more patients asking
questions and i think it's just
persuading people like we do in medicine
anyway to say look actually this
treatment works for you this is really
good for you
etc etc so persuasion is key for us
is it important when you're looking on a
wider scale as a population
is it important that the younger people
who won't necessarily have
such severe covet if they do catch it is
it important that they get the
vaccination
as well as the older population it is
immensely important because we don't
know
what this asymptomatic carriage will
will create
we don't know whether we're able to pass
this virus if we're not affected by it
ourselves so
i think as as we head towards the
june 21st landmark i think we need to be
sure that as many people
are vaccinated as possible younger
people love going out
love enjoying themselves so i think it's
really important that they do
they do get coverage with the
vaccinations what do you say to young
people
who aren't possibly coming forward
because of the hesitancy and the
concerns around the astrozenica vaccine
well what i tend to do is try and
persuade them with the evidence say look
actually
the number of ill effects that you might
get are this percentage
the number of vaccinations that have
been provided so far
are this number and let's look at it
from a global perspective
see how many people have suffered and
sadly passed away with this disease
and i kind of think that that that
persuasion is key for me
and and my team of uh doctors and nurses
and practice
do you offer them a different uh
different jab if they do come in and
they're a certain age
at the moment well i mean i think we
we're advised
by the jcdi that if you're under 40 now
we offer you a fisa vaccination um
so but i mean we don't actually have the
have the ability to offer people what
they want at the
moment apart from the given guidelines i
want to look now
um you spoke about opening up and
vaccinations obviously being so um
intrinsic to that i want to look at the
data and this is from
saturday positive cases up by 23.3
deaths by 43.9 patients admitted to
hospital
23.2 percent um we've always been told
look at the date
data not the dates looking at that data
do you think we should open up on june
the 21st uh kimberley is a very
difficult question isn't it because i
think we
we don't quite know what the future
holds in terms of mutations i think
we've got to
watch the data on a daily basis and see
what's happening and i think
um i would probably if i was advised the
government say urge
caution on on opening up anything if
if the numbers if the figures are going
the wrong way
i think we've been through so much over
the past 14 15 months
to delay maybe the best option if the
figures aren't positive
okay dr meta thank you so much thank you
kimberly thank you
right well let's have a look at some of
the other stories making the news this
morning
and the uk is getting a new national
flagship the first
since the royal yacht britannia was
decommissioned nearly 25 years ago
it'll cost a reported 200 million pounds
and will go around the world
promoting british trade and industry but
the plan
has both supporters and opponents
i think the old royal britannia actually
proved itself as a massive
an important successful trade platform
to promote britain
and what better on building back better
that we can have a new
national flagship built in britain with
uh up-to-date british navionics and
propulsion systems
and you know let's not forget when such
a vessel turns up anywhere in the world
it humbles potentiates and presidents
they all want to be on board
people who remember the old boat suggest
to me that it achieved
really very little in terms of trade
there's no evidence that what we need
now is a boat to increase our trade
those times are long
gone where all you needed to win
international trade was to entertain a
few people on a boat
and back to covert and that issue of
vaccines a reminder tune in to trevor
phillips on sunday after our program
this morning from
half-past the eight he's going to be
talking to the vaccine's minister
nadhim sahawi the uk is to miss out on
billions of pounds in spending from
passengers arriving at heathrow the
economic forecasting group the cebr says
passengers spend
16 billion pounds a year at the airport
sustaining thousands of jobs
it says losses could be averted if the
green travelist is expanded
thousands of people in brazil have
staged nationwide protests
against president jaya bolsonaro and his
response downplaying the pandemic
brazilians protested in at least 16
cities across the country
the president's popularity has plummeted
as well with the number of
deaths approaching half a million
now if it's true that we're heading into
a summer heat wave
many people will be looking towards
britain's wild swimming beauty spots to
cool off
but rivers across the uk are not subject
to the same public health testing as
britain's coastal waters and
sewage is regularly released into them
this guy's charlotte lomas
farley reports
swimming season has arrived here at
warley weir near bath
but you might think twice before getting
in for a dip
as high levels of sewage and chemicals
are plaguing rivers
across the country today because we've
had some quite heavy rainfall after the
last week
when you actually go and look at the
river you can see that it's quite murky
and brown
if you come here on a really nice day in
the summer when we've had dry weather
you can actually see the riverbed
but you can't see that today so on a day
like today i
probably wouldn't put my face in the
water
the problem of pollution is getting
worse one reason is that sewers are
struggling to cope with even light
rainfall
there's such a large quantity of water
gets washed off hard surfaces
that the sewers get filled up and then
they're beyond capacity and
they're either going to back up into
people's homes or they have to be it has
to be released into rivers
and so that's raw sewage coming into
into our rivers which i think is
unacceptable when people want to go
swimming in them
and as more and more people embrace wild
swimming the pressure is on
to make the water safe johnny palmer who
owns the land here is applying for
special bathing status
this would mean the quality of the water
is regularly checked
once we've got designated bathing water
status they're going to test it and know
what's happening with the sewage
and then the environment agency should
issue enforcement action against
upstream polluters like water companies
or farmers or irresponsible businesses
so they'll be compelled to take action
against the polluters
hundreds of rivers in france have been
declared safe to swim in
but only one river here in the uk the
river wharf in
ilkley has been granted bathing status
which means its
water is monitored regularly we're going
to see a sonde
which measures water quality parameters
but measuring water for bathing status
is costly and complex
some water companies say they have
better ways to improve
quality bathing water status doesn't
give people
real-time water quality information from
which to make decisions
uh it measures things and reports them
days later
what people want to know is what's the
water quality like now
so what we're doing is using artificial
intelligence to try and convert
easy to measure data into the really
important data that will affect
public health but this work will take
time
for now it's up to swimmers themselves
to decide if a dip in the river
is worth the risk charlotte lomas sky
news in bath
naz is here for the weather is that
something that appeals to you i mean it
might do over the next day or so because
it's
looking warm and lovely but even with
the sun no no
i'll be honest with you no but for today
yes we're looking at
sunshine for most places some areas will
be rather cool and murky still though
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning sunshine for this sunday
across most of the uk
and ireland but not everywhere there
will be rather murky conditions
and therefore rather cool weather across
some eastern coastal areas
through today in fact this morning it's
a cloudy and murky morning across many
eastern parts of england and across the
northeast as patches of mist and fog
most of it will be burning away very
soon and that will reveal sunny skies
across many inland parts of the uk and
ireland
through this afternoon and the strong
may sunshine coupled with the light
winds today
means it will be a warm day pretty much
everywhere except around those eastern
coastal counties
of england in particular but also over
towards eastern coast of scotland where
it's going to be a cool day
because of the murky conditions lurking
there and that's reflective in the
temperatures but temperatures elsewhere
into the early 20s locally up to around
23 degrees celsius
mainly dry conditions too but the odd
shower or two can't be ruled out mainly
across parts of ireland and northern
ireland
and for scotland
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
still to come we have the sport with rob
um what a game you watch it in croydon
right i did watch it in croydon yeah and
those chelsea fans were very very happy
indeed
i suspect there might be a few saw heads
this morning but all
worth it i imagine because they won the
champions league against manchester city
reaction from that game on the way plus
how brentford boss thomas frank carried
them into england's top flight for the
first time
in more than 70 years
fiery end to the catalan dragons game
against wigan warriors
[Music]
now anyone struggling to get a
last-minute dinner reservation this bank
holiday will be all too aware how eager
we are to get back to dining out
but research from uk hospitality says
the industry is facing a recruitment
crisis with many
reluctant to return to work skies
sherman freeman powell reports
it's lovely to have all our customers
back i mean we're so lucky and we're so
blessed
after 55 years in the same in the same
place that we've built up such good good
will with all our customers
and it's so nice to have everybody
flooding back and uh
and just being so happy with everything
it's a bank holiday weekend
and pubs bars and restaurants are fully
booked with customers
finally able to eat and drink indoors
i'm really sorry we're in the middle of
lunch service at the moment she's very
busy
but whilst punters are desperate to dine
the industry has struggled to find
people to serve them
in the wake of a recruitment crisis i've
never known any of this stuff
the problem that we've really got is
that the fact that all the restaurants
up around the country opened up on the
same day
and then after four months of
effectively no activity
everyone's trying struggling around
trying to find stuff trying to find
kitchen equipment
trying to find uh food wine produce
and it's not just cobia restrictions
they have to contend with
the real issue is a combination of
things it's sort of a perfect storm of
brexit covered in furlough
80 of our members are reporting that
they have vacancies at the moment
and some of them are reporting that they
are struggling to fill those vacancies
so a vacancy rate of 9 that means we are
short of about 180 000
workers across the uk brexit has also
contributed to staff shortages
as eu workers opt to stay in their home
countries
i can place ads on certain job boards
you would always get some response we're
getting
zero nobody's responding
and that is most unusual i've not seen
that before
the government says it's doing
everything it can to support hospitality
to recover
following the reopening of indoor venues
in england earlier this month
shimon freeman powell sky news
joining me now is celine kiazen the
co-owner of the turkish restaurant
oklahoma celine thanks so much for
joining us
um how are you finding recruitment uh a
bit of a nightmare
um just it is a complete perfect storm
at the moment of um
brexit and the pandemic everyone having
been on furlough
and i think it's many people
chefs and front of house workers have
all left the industry
and perhaps had time to sort of reflect
on
what it is that they want to do with
their lives and perhaps decided that you
know hospitality is not for them i think
that's one of the things as well
and and also obviously you know when
when the first lockdown happened many
many people whether they were from
europe or you know further afield from
australia or new zealand we used to get
lots of workers from there as well they
all
went back home why do you think they're
finding that it's not for them
when they have time to reflect on it do
you think it's because there's such
such little job security in the industry
yeah i mean i think that's definitely
one of the things um
you know if we're honest i think that we
all know that it's a very tough industry
it's very demanding
um there are long hours and
the the pay is not always is not always
great because restaurants work on such
fine margins
um and i think as an industry we all
need to
really um stop and stop and look at
what's going on and kind of make
um amendments to kind of draw more
people in
and draw more people in to see this as a
career not just as a
sort of stock gap while they're doing
whatever it is that they're going to be
doing next
i was reading one survey that in
some cities there are as many as 10 jobs
going for one person
what are the figures that you're looking
at i mean you opened your restaurant
2015 in shoreditch from then and now
what does it look like yeah i mean
there is a huge difference to be
absolutely honest once the once the
referendum happened
um immediately you saw a decline
um in cvs coming through any time we
posted um
job ads um but we were still able to
to recruit over the years um but
but now it it is absolutely diabolical i
mean
your post ad and you get very very
little um
people applying if if any at all um and
then
and then when people do you know i've
had this instance in the last
month or so you know give people jobs
and then they decide that they don't
want to work nights or
or something like that or or they don't
want to work so many so many hours
and i'm trying to be as adaptable as
possible but ultimately
you know the nature of the job is is
working evenings that's when restaurants
are open and that's when the demand is
and so um it's very difficult
what are you going to do if you just
can't fill the jobs
that's a good question and for me i mean
i keep um
you know i i'm in a really difficult
situation where i'm looking for
a sous chef at the moment has a very
crucial role
um and i have a number of new people
that were training up
in in kind of senior positions and so um
with all of that going on
we've i i've tried to create you know
this great menu and been very excited
about it but we're having to every week
kind of uh pull back that menu a little
bit and simplify it
and that's what i'll continue to have to
do until
we can find staff basically who who can
cook you know and
um or i mean a worst case scenario i
think as well that we have to sort of
end up limiting
um bookings on on certain nights and
things but we obviously
don't want to do that and that would be
in a very desperate
kind of case scenario because um there
is such a demand for people to go out
and we are fully booked
um for most of the most weeks so
we don't want to be turning away
customers certainly
okay seven thanks so much for talking to
us and good luck with it
thank you
time for the weather nas is here and as
i've been looking outside it looks a bit
murky are you sure it's going to
brighten up
yes i am sure thank you just checking
just checking well you're right to check
but you should have also been listening
because i did say it's a murky start
this morning across central and
eastern areas yep um see me later
but we are going to see lots of sunshine
in the next few hours
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning lots of sunshine for this
sunday across the uk island
but to be fair not everywhere we'll be
experiencing that and especially so this
morning
it's a murky old morning across many
central and eastern parts of england
and across eastern parts of scotland as
well
but the missed fog and low cloud across
these areas that's rolled in off the
north sea through the night will
begin to retract back and burn away
towards coastal areas so
coastal areas of eastern england and
eastern scotland
will continue to be rather murky and
cool through this afternoon
temperatures will be reflective of that
as well but elsewhere temperatures will
respond with the
strong may sunshine that's going to be
developing everywhere in fact it's sunny
for most places this morning anyway
and with the light winds too
temperatures could get up to around 23
degrees celsius locally mainly dry too
but a few isolated showers across the
north and west
and then over the next few days
temperatures go higher and higher
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
7 42 now coming up next we'll look at
the papers with ellie green
she's from the think tank policy
exchange and the journalists and
broadcaster henry bontu
[Music]
i think the seeds were sewn for
retraining when i was younger when i was
18
and a friend suffered from a serious
illness at that time
and also i got a temp job temp agency
sent me up as a ward clark to work in st
thomas's hospital
so i saw some of what went on for
patients and it made a deep impression
on me
and then i was lucky and went into
journalism which was fantastic career
but i also often felt in journalism that
you know you see people you deal with
stories quite quickly
and then you move on and you i always
wondered what would be happening for
those people afterwards so i think that
was the kind of thing that
pushed me towards medicine i think both
careers are really valuable
and do different things but yeah the
opportunity to be with people and
making those relationships and helping
them in their time of need is is very
rewarding
indeed i'd watched a lot of er when i
was younger and i had a sort of stupid
idea about the glamour of medicine from
that
and it's definitely not glamorous um
it's it's hard work
and it's grueling and you see a lot of
stuff that stays with you
um so there's a lot of pressure on our
shoulders but that carries with it also
benefit of feeling feeling valuable and
we get to help people sometimes and see
them come through things and that's
incredibly rewarding as well
so yeah on balance i i sometimes feel a
bit jealous of
you guys but no i'm really happy
medicine is all about listening
and communication and so yeah the skills
are very very useful indeed
um and in and in medicine people are are
you know here to come come and tell you
their story and often hearing the story
is as important as
diagnosing the illness and providing the
treatment it's been very very difficult
for
for doctors but also more particularly
for patients so the arms length thing
on the phone most of the time through
videos sometimes and
we yeah it's risky it's more risky
business we've had a lot of patients
who've
suffered from the lack of contact and
the lack of available services in
general
so it's been really really tough but
we've had to make do with what's
possible and try and prevent the spread
of the uh
the illness and you know in the surgery
too
um one of the stories in the book is
about a woman who um who
died in the end of covid and part of
that was
part of the reason why she died was she
ended up in hospital she essentially put
herself in hospital
and then caught the virus in the
hospital and loneliness was behind that
so um there are lots of different ways
in which this pandemic can get you
and um yeah it's been a very very
difficult year
hello my name is nadia frontier
my name is ryan matthews i'm the marine
assistant
at rather research station which is to
the west of the west antarctic peninsula
[Music]
so far i've been here for five months
and it is an absolutely wonderful
experience
did you know that driving us to school
creates extra toxic air
at drop-off and pick-up times
murky conditions will burn back to
eastern coasts by midday leaving most of
the uk
island with a good deal of sunshine for
this afternoon it'll be another mainly
dry day too apart from some isolated
showers in the far northwest
feeling widely warm as well but cooler
along eastern coast
where it'll remain murky pollen levels
will be moderate over most of england
wales and northern ireland today however
scotland will experience
low levels the risk of grass pollen will
increase as more species start flowering
but
fungal spores and weed pollen are
increasing to a medium risk
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
let's have a look at the papers now and
with us this morning ellie green from
the think tank
policy exchange and the journalism
broadcaster henry bonsu hello again to
you both
um ellie let's start with you this
question of the wuhan
lab leak it just won't go away why are
we talking about this again it's on the
front of the sunday times
yes so this is news now that british
spies or british intelligence
have now deemed that it is feasible that
coronavirus leaked from the wuhan lab
um this is following on from reports uh
that three people three researchers at
the wuhan institute of virology
got sick back in november 2019 and were
treated in hospital and so this is again
giving fuel to the fire of what was
previously at the start of the pandemic
uh
uh deemed almost a conspiracy theory
that coronavirus could come
out of this lab um but
poor people are calling for
gratification into this obviously
president joe biden
um over in the states and you also have
tom tugginhart who's chairman of the
foreign affairs select committee here
pushing for an investigation into this
issue
and um calling for greater transparency
from china
i think you know there's has to be some
healthy skepticism on whether we're
going to get that clarity and that
transparency
from china um also this report is noting
that we have quite a few
um human sources of intelligence on the
ground in china
so it's going to be quite difficult i
think to actually work out what went on
and um there is there is the likelihood
that we may perhaps never know
henry what do you think well just
picking up on what ellie said there
about the lack of
human intelligence sources in china
we've got that problem
um in other parts of the world so it's
really going to test
western intelligence the question is
whether or not they can get what they
need
uh from um potential sources on the dark
web from people who
can post information there without fear
of being caught but it's really going to
stretch them
and it clearly exposes um the
deficiencies and perhaps a lack of
resources that have been
put into this area and if we want to
stop this
from happening again then of course yeah
you've got to really work on that human
intelligence
those sources and try to find out what
really happened because the chinese of
course
um very very um wary of how they look
and very very sensitive but any
accusations that they
did this either accidentally or
deliberately and pointing the finger
in repos at the u.s
um henry will stay with you talk to us
about uh it's also on yeah sunday times
the mod's new diversity chief what's he
what's he up to
well here's the thing you know it's a
she
yeah you see how you can you see yeah
exactly that's terrible i am
sorry kimberly what are you doing oh my
gosh henry no let's move on
okay yeah so what is she doing let's
dwell on this for a second
okay because she's called samantha the
forge she was appointed last year 110
000 pounds a year
a diversity supremo and one of the
things she's going to do
is look at traditional ranks and titles
that might be considered
gender bias so rifleman an able-bodied
seamen midshipman
airman even the first sea lord could we
have a first sea lady
now remember women have only been
allowed to serve in all combat roles
since 2018 and the previous i mean
so the previous titles were left to
those particular units and they decided
whether or not we want to keep
historical titles or change them
and they decided pretty much unanimously
to keep them
but now the new director of diversity
etc and equality
has said we must look at this again and
so it's a certainty time speculating
as to what she might do and which titles
might be in her sights
yet another front you might say in the
culture wars but this time in the
military
interesting okay we'll keep an eye on
that one um ellie
what's going on still sunday times
victims will be able to get their phone
back after a day
to boost rape convictions what is what
is this about
yeah so i think this is definitely
welcome news that um rape victims will
be
will be getting to get their phone back
very quickly now
um this is an effort to increase the
convictions um
for for rape and to also alleviate the
distress
for a lot of women um and men also who
who then have to give up their phones
and
feel that they're very violated by the
by that process
i mean there's there's a mention in here
that um one woman had her phone taken
away from her for two years
so this is a really serious issue and
also i think the police are trying to
commit to the fact that they're going to
act quicker
and they're going to do something to
increase this rate of conviction which
over the last five years has
fallen dramatically from i believe 8.3
to 1.5
which is just absolutely shocking so
there's a real effort here to make it um
much better for victims and encourage
victims to come forward and to try and
yeah as i said
alleviate a lot of the distress around
obviously what is such a traumatic
experience and the
you know increased trauma and then going
through this whole police investigation
um let's go to the express henry
so much was being discussed about this
license fee and then of course with the
martin bashir revelations it came out
again with that report
they do have a review a half term
review um next year but campaigners are
calling now for a
a vote or a referendum about the license
fee
yeah well it's important to say which
campaign is it's defund the bbc i'm not
sure
how many people belong to that but they
are listened to
and are frequently quoted by certain
newspapers and the sunday express
has done a telephone poll 98 of its
readers want the bbc to lose the license
fee
not much surprise there but that
campaign group says
that the martin bashir affair shows that
the bbc is
out of touch it's arrogant and beyond
reform
and this interesting statistic the
public accounts committee
has reported that around 200 000 more
households each year
decide not to pay the license fee and i
think not paying it has now been
decriminalized the big concern is if the
bbc and the way
in which it's funded is changed then um
how much money will it lose and how will
it this how will this affect programming
because
if you've been to the states you've been
to other countries what passes for
public service broadcasting there is
nothing compared to what we have here so
if the 3.7 or so billion
that we get from the license fee is
massively salary slice
and reduce well think about some of the
crown jewels of the bbc
you know so line of duty that's exactly
what i thought of
them we will not have these programs and
we will start complaining
ellie what do you think do you think
it's going to be scrapped
well i mean there has obviously been
increasing calls for that i don't think
that hopefully the bbc is beyond reform
i think we all
love the bbc and would like to see it
working um
in the best way possible but yeah i
think that decriminalizing it was a good
step
um and i think that ultimately we may be
on the road to that with the increase in
subscription services and everybody
using netflix and different things now
i think we may see um a difficulty in
maintaining it for much longer
okay can i add one more go ahead go
ahead
yeah okay so people are saying that bbc
is out of touch in arrogant and beyond
reform but we say that about pretty much
every british institution
you know or english you know church of
england uh the police
there are so many institutions judiciary
we did the same thing this debate
is about that report isn't it into the
whole diana interview and it was
extremely damning
it was extremely damning but let's
remember this was one particular program
um and one particular interview out of
the whole ecology of the bbc
so many of the other programs don't have
that kind of structure
and yes ultimately they have the same
directory general board of governors and
now
ofcom but you can't attack the whole of
the bbc
programming empire or let me not use the
word empire uh
programming universe for what a
particular group of people did
okay um we're gonna leave the bbc there
ellie very briefly
hot hot hot hot hot hot
yes this is the very welcome news that
we're apparently gonna see
six heat waves this summer um so let's
see if that pans out obviously the daily
star being very optimistic about what we
have to hope for over
over the coming months um and i think
everyone will be harking back to what we
had last year obviously
deep into the pandemic but we did have
that really great summer
so um let's hope that they're right and
that we are going to sleep
yeah let's hope ellie henry has really
been such fun thank you so much have a
great sunday
thank you still to come on sky news
breakfast we'll have the latest reaction
to the news that the prime minister
and carrie simons would tie the knot
[Music]
you